um
david was a lovely man and and a dear
friend of mine in fact his office was
just around the corner
to my office in one parliament street
and and today is an enormous tragedy for
his family his loved ones uh his friends
and and actually for the whole of
parliament and the whole of the nation
uh because david uh
had been in parliamentarian for some
40-yard years nearly 40 years
and he had contributed to the governance
of this country in those
four decades and
was loved by his constituents he was a
determined constituency mp if you look
at his contributions in the house of
commons he was always putting his
constituency first
but above all
he was a wonderful and lovely man and
and
always had advice to give to people who
were new in the house and i remember
when i was in ump uh he was one of the
first to say if ever you need any help
or advice don't hesitate to ask i've
been here for a while
uh and you could see him again now um in
the tea room in the dining room or
wherever uh he would be talking with the
new members uh making sure that they
were comfortable and everything else but
really um it has come as an enormous
shock uh and as i say he was a personal
friend uh and uh i will miss his uh uh
his his forever smile uh and whenever
there were votes we'd often bump into
each other
in the lift as we went down towards the
commons to vote and then we'd walk back
uh and it was only recently relatively
recently that um he launched one of his
books
and because of the pandemic he was
unable to have a proper book launch
so what david did
is that around the regions of the
country he got some mps to do a
question and answer session which went
out by zoom
and i was privileged to
ask him some questions recently when he
did his book launch in fact he was
thinking of doing another book um and
there was just so much to do i mean i
remember the various conversations i've
had with him and it was all always about
you know what to do next to
improve the lives of his constituents
but also uh the lives of everyone in the
uk um a great tragedy and and
we'll all miss him enormously
yeah as you described they're an
indefatigable man deeply committed
to not just his constituents but his
friends also
a family man a husband and a father to
five children
uh yes and and um a devout christian as
well
which he didn't
make a big deal of but
he was
very religious and
that faith of his kept him going
and yes a very much a family man in fact
when i first made a government whip in
2010 um david was one of the people who
was part of the group uh for whom i was
the the whip and i got to know him very
well uh during those early days and
that's a friendship that uh we've
maintained but a huge huge loss
for his family and and the tragedy is
that he will have left this morning
um in his with his usual smile
with his uh usual good humor and
as events have unfolded um he won't be
returning home uh and and and that is a
real real tragedy
uh for his family and as i said earlier
on our hearts and thoughts and prayers
uh go out to his family to his loved
ones to his friends
the other mp of course who didn't return
home after attending a constituency
surgery was the labour mp
joe cox back in 2016.
does there need to be a review of
mp security i was talking to lord eric
pickles short while ago who said no this
is just part
of an mp's job what do you think
sam i i think
it's difficult to say
how much more security
there can be because
whilst this was an incident at the
surgery
and likewise with joe cox
remember mps attend various functions
and the leaflets are sent out to people
saying there's going to be such and such
an event and
such and such mp will be attending i
some
a few days ago attended the reopening of
one of my village halls after some
refurbishment works and i'd agreed to
attend weeks beforehand
and they made the message out to all the
other villagers that i would be
attending so
it is difficult that when you go to an
event like that
to what extent do you say people need to
be policed or checked or whatever i
don't think it's possible i think
there is
certainly an element that you know we as
mps
need to always constantly review our
security both for ourselves and indeed
for our staff uh and remember today
there will have been david staff there
as well and they also uh will be shocked
at what's happened today we mustn't
forget then but
i think there's an element of basically
trying to get the message out that
violence never been wins
we should learn to disagree respectfully
um
yes you know by all means have that
disagreement uh but it should never
resort to this sort of sort of level and
the other thing to remember sam is that
for example in my constituency it is
some
300 square miles it's difficult to have
one place where i have my surgeries um
because i take the view that i should be
going to people and so i have
a revolving surgery